yay I'm here with the gabbie show it's
it weird to call you but like a username
no it's it is what it is you know what I
mean
and it was Gabi the human being
wonderful youtuber and biner we just
reported an episode of not too deep
which you can go listen to the full
episode on iTunes or SoundCloud after
you're done watching this challenge that
we are about to partake in it's called
the Edward spooky hands challenge very
excited I'm also excited and as always
completely nervous for some reason about
into every challenge we do and right
before it happens I get just a wave of
anxiety adrenaline it's yeah it's fun
we're having fun okay but damn it so
here's how this works
like Edward forty hands the popular
drinking game drink responsibly we are
going to be taping these pumpkins
instead of forties to our hands and then
we will race in a series of Halloween
themed mini events first we have to open
and eat a tiny Snickers then we have to
try and chug a pumpkin spice latte which
we just said this is my first diversity
one of the season this is our first one
this isn't how appropriate that we don't
savor it at all and then the last thing
we have to do is wrap ourselves in
toilet paper like a mummy until we run
out of the roll and run or so wrap
ourselves in toilet paper and once the
roll is complete you have to scream
trick or treat and if you speak I curse
that with no pumpkin I know okay for the
for the sanctity of fairness Jack fairy
will be taping us up right now I have a
nice little hook of an advantage get
that out of there get that out of that
water toilet paper it is a lot of toilet
paper so how you want it you should grip
it oh you should take off your rings oh
ah
the tiny pack attacks start to happen
when you realize that you have no
mobility in your hands oh I like the
festive orange tape by the way yeah Jack
very there's all these decorations
I can't take credit for Jack Barry have
you ever played at recording room um I
think in theory but like I always just
kind of like okay I'm going in with my
hands like this beer got warm really bad
a lot of beer
it's a lot of beer too much a little
drunk this is you know this is great I
have never felt better
no not ruin my manicure Jack Barry all
right respect oh yeah that's a nice
manicure so shitty or Oh Paula no I
would show you how my fingers like I
walk we establish a safe word a same way
the safe word is take these off my hands
you don't want this one to be to die
here over this one's like completely
back looks great it's all right you know
what
oh we got the on your mark get set go
yeah okay scotch fruit out Oh
every minute no I'm trying to use my
hand got it nah
Wow give me the flicker
yeah are you getting it I shoot my Jesus
over my Invisalign
I need this far out come on sit down
Dom come in here we got jobs she never
been a bad home oh my god this is so
much younger
but it is delicious
are you okay do you you ain't the rapper
oh how do this just an everything I
think you're gonna be so pissed and
wasted oh I don't think there are any
winners in this challenge
so I sure did help us a joke that yes
that was very impressive like that was
really weird that might be the most
honest reaction of everything well Gabby
thank you for participating in that okay
thank you for allowing me to be a part
of this I mean if you're gonna have your
first pumpkin spice latte of the season
thank you make sure you guys go listen
to the full podcast if you are into
ghosts hmm if you're into online dating
and if you're into more ghosts there's a
lot of that conversation on soundcloud
and itunes and not too deep also make
sure that you go check out I'm out of
breath yeah make sure you go check out
the gabbie show across all social media
platforms especially here on YouTube
edifying Panda yeah I don't know got
this black leotard and then I painted as
a spider web and then in each one I put
a lie that people tell but they were
like all over my butt my boobs so like
people are like really up in my butt
reading like the lies written oh my gosh
that's amazing